some of the cgi from harry potter really  did not hold up especially compared to  better versions of similar creations  quidditch looked pretty awful in the  philosopher's stone with very fake  looking backdrops but by the time the  half-blood prince came around the scenes  were far more satisfying to watch  this troll looks anything but real the  facial features are odd and it moves  very awkwardly gop who we meet later in  the series is similar but definitely  created with better cgi voldemort is  always terrifying but it was  particularly bad when his face appeared  on the back of professor quirrell's head  these wild cornish pixies look like  they're straight out of a video game yet  dobby's thoughtful creation is  completely endearing firenze the centaur  looks like an odd plastic model not even  appearing to be breathing but the  centaurs in the fifth film improved with  some more realistic details and  movements